I wrote the book every weekend for a
year and that was a great part of my
journey of integrating those things
doing the research finding out what
science could explain the laws of
attraction but then actually it was the
response to the book that I think really
hit me emotionally that how much people
wanted a very clear pragmatic
explanation of what you have to do with
your brain and your thinking and your
feeling and your action to bring the
things that you want into your life so
I'll start with visualization and vision
boards I kind of the science behind them
is is quite similar so it's basically
about three processes that happen in the
brain and they are selective filtering
selective attention and value tagging
basically we're bombarded with so much
information and this has been the case
for a long time but if you read a copy
of the New York Times today you would
receive as much information from that
one newspaper as somebody would in their
entire lifetime 100 years ago and even
then they were overly bombarded with
information so the brain has a natural
filtering mechanism which is that you
don't need to notice things that aren't
really relevant to your survival so for
example you don't notice your clothes on
your body all day we need to direct that
filtering system otherwise in a way
we're still wired just to survive and
reproduce need motivation watch top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn from one of the best
Dr Tara sword Bieber and my take on our
top 10 was a success
Joy
things that will help us to thrive in
the modern world may not necessarily be
filtered in unless we're presenting
visual images to our brain on a daily
basis or sitting down and closing our
eyes and you know visualizing the things
that we want in our life for a certain
outcome if we do those practices then
the next process comes in which is
selective attention which is that you
notice the things that you're
visualizing or you have on your vision
board it's like when you buy a new car
and then you suddenly see it everywhere
um so it's basically priming your brain
to notice opportunities that will take
you closer to your goals and then value
tagging is the brain's system of putting
things in order of importance and it
does this in two ways it does it in a
cold or logical way under warm or
emotional way so The Logical things are
basically the survival you know the
basics that we need to survive like roof
over our head food on the table
um and the warmer things are the ones
that we might choose to put on our
vision board so they're the things you
know our dreams our desires goals that
show that we're thriving rather than
just kind of you know surviving
so by repeatedly exposing your brain to
these images you're priming it to not
just notice but also grasp the
opportunities that will take you closer
to what you want and that's why I call
vision boards action boards because I
don't believe that you can create this
fantasy image and sit at home and wait
for it to come true I believe that you
need to be out there networking dating
whatever it is
um to get the things that you want rule
number two is keep your brain healthy
what are the things that we can do to
improve our brain performance
so we talk about things like
rest which is sleep and also sort of
downtime nutrition is super important so
the brain is obviously a tiny proportion
of your body weight and only weighs a
few kilos but it uses up up to 30
percent of the breakdown products of
what you eat so when you're asleep your
brain is is eating up 20 of what you ate
that day
when you're at work
um and focused on something it's using
up about a quarter of what you eat and
when you're stressed it's easing up up
to 30 percent oh well yeah and so
obviously people think what should I eat
if I want to be healthy generally or I
want to lose weight or I want to build
muscle mass but the sorts of people that
you know like you and the people that I
work with
aren't thinking enough about what should
I be eating so I can make the best
decisions today what should I be eating
so I can solve complex problems what
should should I be eating so I can
understand what's going on like in terms
of interpersonal Communication in my
teeth with my team for example
and then this everything from hydration
exercise
um breathing mindfulness curiosity like
there's there's so many factors that
contribute
to brain health and
they're probably not dissimilar to
things as a doctor that you would know
contribute to cardiovascular health or
gastrointestinal Health but
you know we at Heights feel that if you
approach everything with a brain care
first attitude then you're kind of
taking care of the rest of the stuff
like if you eat and drink in a way
that's good for your brain your skin and
your hair are going to look nicer I mean
and I that sounds like a such a girly
thing to say but people make a lot of
really important choices based on
what they look like and and that's fine
and that probably has like beneficial
effects on our in our brains and our
guts as well but considering this organ
is so energy hungry and it's so
important in terms of everything else
that happens in your body
I feel like we need to flip that
narrative so that it's starting with
okay what can I what things can I do
today that are going to be the best for
my brain rule number three is focus on
the good things one of the things about
being conscious and not being on
autopilot is is basically controlling
what you expose your brain to because
the more you expose it to bad news the
more you're likely to live life through
fear we know for example that people who
repeatedly looked at images of the Twin
Towers going down who had no personal
connection to New York could get PTSD
I mean it's it's incredible that just
exposing yourself repeatedly to bad news
especially with visual imagery can
actually traumatize you in a way that
you know you can't easily get over so
I'm very very careful about what I look
at what I read
um you know my social media feeds are
carefully controlled to be as positive
as possible
um you're absolutely right that if you
don't think about it and you look at bad
news just before you go to sleep then
you think about young children you've
got young children even if they you know
read a book that's not that scary but
maybe has some monsters in it then they
can have nightmares they can feel
frightened
um so yeah everything that we expose our
brain to has an impact and we need to be
much more mindful of that especially
because the gearing of the brain it's
two to two and a half times more likely
to focus on negatives and positives so
we need to be feeding our brain more
positive things to keep ourselves
confident
um and you know moving forward
positively rule number four is learn
about neuroplasticity neuroplasticity is
the ability of the brain to grow and
change and you see that very clearly in
children from zero to two where they go
from being completely helpless and
vulnerable to walking talking managing
their own bowels and bladders pretty
incredible
um there's a lot of change that goes on
during the teenage years as well it's
more pruning a way of neural Pathways
that you don't need anymore and
Readiness for socialization and
reproduction
and then we used to think that that
process really slowed down or became
quite passive from 25 to 60 well we used
to think from 18. now we know it's very
active till 25. and what we also know is
that if you do things to keep your brain
flexible it you can make changes
absolutely from 25 to 65 and maybe even
beyond that so I believe that
manifestation is neuroplasticity the
process is underlied
um by neuroplasticity which is that you
have
a certain way of thinking Behavior
patterns habits
and the more you repeat them
and the more emotional intensity is
associated with them the stronger those
Pathways become also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is practice proper
manifestation in the last 25 years or so
we have had much more sophisticated
brain scanning technology which shows
how the brain works prior to that we
really we understood a lot of how the
brain works from seeing what happens
when it goes wrong so if somebody has a
stroke or a brain tumor or a brain
injury once we could scan healthy brains
we started to learn a lot more about
this concept of neuroplasticity which is
that the brain grows and changes
throughout life
now you've got two little girls so you
will know that from zero to two they
went from being completely vulnerable
and helpless to walking talking being
able to control their bladder and bowels
and you know maybe even speaking several
languages and having an opinion so it's
a massive burst of neuroplasticity and
we see that you know very visibly in
young children
um around the teenage years there's some
pruning of the brain to sophisticate it
for adulthood for sexual behavior
emotional and social interaction
and that is quite an active process till
we're about 25. we used to think it
stopped when we physically stopped
stopped growing around the age of 18.
but the really interesting area
for us in manifestation and the laws of
attraction is that from 25 to 65 you can
do things that keeps your brain more
plastic or flexible
and you can change the ways that you
think feel and act
so to me neuroplasticity underlies
manifestation and it's a four-step
process it starts with raised awareness
so you need to know what you want to
bring into your life or how you want
your life to look
or feel
um then it's focused attention which is
noticing
maybe you know negative thinking or
certain behaviors or relationship
patterns that are holding you back from
getting what you want
and also noticing
opportunities to get the things that you
want but really just building up your
database of okay that doesn't work for
me when I do this then you know good
things come into my life
the third part is deliberate practice so
that is
going out there and doing the things
that you need to to manifest the things
that you want into your life gotta do
the work got to do the work totally
um and the fourth part isn't really like
a step in the process but it's
accountability because it's very easy to
start particularly a new year and say
okay these are all my resolutions and
new things that I'm going to do and then
for most of us that motivation doesn't
you know remain
partly from the Neuroscience that's
because we tend to pick goals that are
too big and it's better to break them
down into bite-sized chunks and that's
the same for manifestation take small
steps towards the things that you want
so if there are some things that are
more in your control like getting fit
and healthy then start doing that and
then if there's something that's less in
your control like getting married or
having a baby then
give that a bit longer but know that you
are changing your brain by changing your
behaviors and you know you have some
form of accountability whether it's a
vision board whether it's your partner
whether it's a therapist well number six
is start journaling what does the
Neuroscience or evidence say around why
journaling is legit
yeah so um
at the very minimum it's like a download
of your emotions and so with your you
know any emotions uh negative thoughts
unfinished tasks if you keep them in
your brain body system by just thinking
about them in your mind then you
actually increase your cortisol levels
and cortisol correlates with stress so
it's like it's like a pressure cooker
building up if you speak it out loud
write it out into a journal or do
physical exercise and literally sweat
out some of that cortisol then you're
releasing those negative emotions
negative thought patterns
anxieties you know worries about the
future from your brain body system
but I have and I'd love to know if
you've done this or not I have I had an
Insight which I just stumbled across by
myself but it really makes sense
obviously from the neuroplasticity point
of view is that if you go back and read
over your Journal you see your thought
process laid out in front of you you see
your patterns of behavior you see like
your decision making tools whether it's
more logical or more intuitive you see
what you've written about your
relationships with people and
seeing that in your own handwriting or
you know even if it's been synced up and
typed out for you just just seeing
knowing that it's your words and what
you've thought and what you've said
you can't run away from that so it can
be like so insightful and enlightening
and I've had that definitely with all of
that stuff like emotions and thought
patterns and intuition but
I also had it when I was I used to go to
Boston twice a year to teach at MIT and
I remember with the travel and the jet
lag just feeling that I was having these
small muscular twitches and it was
noticeable in bed at night
and
I decided to read back out not for that
reason but just anyway I decided to read
back over my journal from six months
earlier when I was last in Boston and
I'd written in my journal I'm getting
these little muscular twitches and so I
worked out that I'd become magnesium
deficient by flying and so I basically
hence why I was carrying so many bottles
of things with me when I was traveling
really upped my dose of magnesium
um for the trips and it never happened
again oh wow and if I hadn't read back I
would never put two and two together I
would have thought it was just happening
now and it hadn't happened before rule
number seven is make small progress
daily I try to do the right things about
sleep and everything else but I don't
get stressed about it if I can't yeah
um so that's that's a really big thing
for me you know I try to eat right I try
to remember to take my supplements I
Journal when I can I meditate when I can
um but if I don't do it then I don't get
stressed I would say that is a really
big learning for me I think that that's
really really big tip I would also say
it's better to change 10 things by one
percent than try to change one thing by
ten percent so work on micro tweaks to
your routine like go to bed half an hour
earlier do a digital detox over one
weekend
um drink a bit more water than you
normally do try to increase your steps
by one to two thousand per day for a
week and see what happens so small
things like that build up because you
start to feel better your brain becomes
more powerful and then you're able to do
you know some of the bigger goals that
you may have been saving up rule number
eight is increase your water intake 75
of the brain is made up of water and of
the solid matter 60 is made up of fat so
the focus should be on good fats and
hydrating Foods in your diet so that's
like oily fish if you eat fish
um eggs if you eat eggs and then avocado
nuts seeds olive oils
um obviously leafy greens but
particularly hydrating foods like
cucumber melon and then the best foods
for your brain are dark-skinned Foods so
like beets black beans eggplant and the
good news is that dark chocolate over 80
percent and organic coffee count in that
too because in the skins of dark Foods
there's a something called anthocyanins
which are really strong antioxidants
that support your brain protect it from
inflammation but also support growth of
new cells
um
so I just try to eat as many of those
things as I can also because of the gut
brain connection fermented foods so like
Cafe kombucha sauerkraut kimchi
um and then you know just just eating
around that the sort of right proportion
of protein fat and carbs so just not too
much carbs but some whole grains you
need to make serotonin for example
um the hydration equation is half a
liter of water for every 30 pounds of
your body weight
so you need to work out what that ideal
number is and then see where you're at
at the moment and if there's a big gap
just increase it by one glass of water
per day over a sort of you know one to
two week period otherwise you're going
to notice you're going to the bathroom a
lot more rule number nine is sleep with
good posture can we spend a moment on
sleep posture yeah of course I actually
did a reel for you on um Instagram yeah
and I was saying that
the best position for cleaning out your
brain overnight which is a very active
forcible flushing process of getting rid
of the sort of toxins that build up
through the wear and tear of daily life
um and this process takes seven to eight
hours is lying on your side so basically
left or right side but that's better
than lying on your front or your back
and it's something to do with the
positioning of the vessels in your neck
um
so basically the fluid that the brain
sits in which also is you know there are
ventricles in the brain that forces
toxins out overnight and if your head is
to the side then it's easier to expel
them it's called the glymphatic system
in the brain but basically it goes into
your lymphatic system and then gets
expelled from your body yeah so intra is
I've actually I love it yeah side
sleeping yeah
I have a special pillow that makes me
sleep on my side oh really what is it
it's a temporal memory foam pillow
that's got a ridge so that it fits
nicely into the side of your head and
neck and shoulder and Rule Number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is spend time in nature you
mentioned nature and looking at the
stars and stuff
what's inherently good about nature yeah
so this has really come up as a big one
in the last few years and I don't I'm
not sure if it's coincidental with the
pandemic and having been locked up or
locked up but also had more opportunity
to maybe commune with nature than you we
did in our hectic Lifestyles before
but the brain benefits of time spent in
nature are massive
and
I whenever I asked a question that I
don't necessarily factually know the
answer to straight away always take it
back to evolution
there's a reason that our brains were
wider in a certain way and
and when we first became you know homo
sapiens
we walked on the Savannah we walked in
the land we we ate what we could hunt
fish or heart or harvest and so our
relationship with nature was was
you know we were dependent on it but it
was also a huge threat to us floods
storms you know fires
um it's the symbiotic relationship and
what we've done through Agriculture and
construction is just move ourselves
further and further away from that and
even if you just think of one like super
scientific example of that is that the
quality and diversity of our gut Flora
has diminished so much since we lived in
the cave it's it's like reduced by I
don't want to get the number wrong but
it's a shocking Factor like hundreds
um
and agricultures contribute to that
antibiotics have contributed to that to
that like obviously antibiotics save
lives and you know it's been an amazing
advance for us as humans but
um
the fact that we eat food that's
not as diverse as it used to be
that we don't necessarily eat those
Natural Things the Prebiotic and
Probiotic foods and supplements that
allow our gut bacteria to flourish and
we eat so much processed food
um
and that stress alcohol and antibiotics
or damage our gut microbiome
that's one of the huge consequences of
of um
having moved away from nature
and people ask all sorts of questions
that we don't know all the answers to
yet about why do we have more diseases
like me like Ms like autism like add and
some of the answers lie in that
disconnection from nature and what
that's done to how that's shaped our
bodies and our brains right
um and how we live as a result of that
just take one minute to look at a leaf
or a petal or
a squirrel or something like that's like
close up right in front of you in great
detail
and then take one minute to look at a
really large tree or building or a cloud
in the distance
and just see how that resets your
nervous system so there's a couple of so
that that's basically taking yourself
away from sharp Focus to a wide Vista
which is part of like living in nature
and on the Savannah is that we we love
having an uninterrupted view of the
Horizon it's really restful for the
brain yeah okay and then as well as like
10 deep breaths you can just do like you
can take you can do a sharp intake of
breath and just do like a really long
sigh as well that's a nice little way to
reset your nervous system
we've developed an appreciation for
things that we may have taken for
granted before so I have been
um in lockdowns I've been with one other
person and it has certainly made me
think
at first I was like well if I'd been on
my own I would have been fine but as the
months drag on and as it happens again
and again I just my heart just is
so out there for people who've been
through that on their own that is not a
healthy state for us and so a lot of the
work I've done in the last year is to
encourage people to bathe rather than
shower because immersing yourself in
warm water releases the same bonding
hormones that you get from physical
affection from a loved one
to massage your own body to do gratitude
practices that involve self-touch
um so a lot more you know being a lot
more proactive about the fact that you
maybe can have been isolated alone but
also even with one affectionate person
or you know two or three affectionate
people in your family it's normal in a
day to go out and shake hands or hug or
kiss like eight to twelve people and so
that happens and you don't even really
think about it and they say that you
need eight hugs a day just to sort of
stay mentally stable and 20 hugs a day
to grow as a you know as a person who
feels
healthy and happy and they can take some
risks so I think suddenly demanding 20
hugs a day from one person is probably
you know so if your brain has seen
something
or experienced it through mental
rehearsal then
when it comes across something similar
in real life it's less threatening
so uncertainty is the most threatening
thing to your brain anything new is a
huge threat to your brain which is kind
of counter to neuroplasticity right
because with neuroplasticity I make
myself do something new every year so
I've learned several languages really
yeah how many languages do you know now
um I've learned five in my life I'm not
going to pretend
um are you fluent in any yeah so I was
very lucky I was brought up bilingual in
English in an Indian language and then
from the age of nine I learned French at
school wow um
and then as an adult I learned three
other languages at different times
um probably not so good at those as well
um yeah so during
the pandemic
I
I actually made a statement in the
beginning which was
don't necessarily put pressure on
yourself to like start a new career or
learn a language then it went on for
longer than we all thought it would
um so I was actually on an Instagram
live saying that I'd always wanted to
learn the piano
and somebody sent me a DM and said Dr
Tara you can use the flow key app to
teach yourself piano Loki huh yeah
um it's a really really cool app and um
I'd been gifted a piano keyboard for
Christmas by my husband I am ashamed to
say a year or two earlier and never used
it
um so in the pandemic I did I did use
the Floki app and teach myself
um now you know how to play piano
yeah and um
doesn't give me tennis lessons and then
I thought okay
if I can learn piano and I can learn
tennis and I can see how much I improve
and I can see the muscle memory from
when I played tennis from when I was at
High School
can I apply that to
looking at life through a happier lens
so it's a natural default for all of us
to you know loss aversion is one of the
biggest gearings of the brain and is
essential to survival loss aversion yeah
so avoiding loss and uncertainty like I
said we don't like that so we like
things to be safe we like them to be the
same you know we like to know what's
going to happen
and and equally we like you know the
brain wants to look out for danger to
protect us
and during the pandemic I'd been
speaking for a few years about having a
sabbatical and a few people said to me
oh now you can have a sabbatical
and I said you know I'm locked up at
home I can't travel I can't see my
friends I can't hug my stepson it's not
a sabbatical it's not the sabbatical I
dreamed of and also
the mental health requirements were so
vast that I felt I had to do my piece
and really you know speak to that
through Instagram through zoom and try
to help people so I was actually busier
with work than ever before trying to
help people yeah but I did start you
know I saw a lot of relationship
breakups I saw a lot of people get sick
you know a lot of people that I
personally knew died during the pandemic
and
it was easy to start to feel like to
focus on things like you can't see
people you can't travel and
I didn't
I didn't want to see myself go down that
road
so I actually I got a coach you know I
believe in having therapy having
coaching having supervision I love it
um and I worked on on that and she
actually said to me why can't you apply
neuroplasticity to being happier
and because it's intangible it's
you know you can make a vision board
with a house and you know a
a dream holiday and vacation and all
that for the material world exactly how
do you create one for the emotional
world I think there are and that's why
imagery is important because it can
evoke a feeling yes
um but I remember the moment I was
standing sort of at the door to my
garden
and a really small nice thing had
happened and I thought isn't that lovely
and and I I actually checked myself and
I thought I notice when something goes
wrong all the time
I don't always acknowledge when
something goes right or is really good
and happy and so I could tell that I had
I had changed that I was noticing those
things you didn't notice that before I
mean I'm sure I did sometimes with like
big things the longer we have been
experiencing something the more deeply
entrenched it is in our brain
and that's why the neural Pathways that
relate to things like the values that we
hold the roles that we play in our
family and Social Circle
how boundaried we are or not
the expectations that we place on
ourselves and the secrets that we keep
can be so deeply embedded in the neural
architecture of our brains that we're
not really aware of how much they drive
our Behavior
so essentially these are subconscious or
non-conscious beliefs that drive our
thinking processes and then drive the
actions that we take in the real world
the good news is that through
neuroplasticity you can choose
Sustainable New behaviors that will
overwrite those old neural Pathways that
you have in your brain
it's important to remember that
neuroplasticity can work for good or for
bad so you also need to be so mindful of
what you're exposing your brain to
everything you see on the TV reading the
news the people that you meet and the
emotions that you experience and the
thoughts that you let go round and round
in your brain
now there's a process for embedding
sustainable Behavior change in your
brain and that starts with raised
awareness so you really have to bring
from non-conscious to conscious what it
is that's driving your behaviors and
thinking processes at the moment
you can do that through meditation
journaling therapy or just talking to
good friends
once you've identified what might be
holding you back from success what
barriers you may be placing in front of
yourself or just old patterns of
thinking and behavior that no longer
serve you you can start to focus
attention on certain situations or
relationships where these behaviors tend
to show themselves up
at first it's important just to notice
where you could have done something
differently rather than jumping straight
into action
once you've spent some time reflecting
on this and you have a few good examples
of ways that you think or behave that
you'd like to change you can start the
third step of deliberate practice
which is choosing a new way of Behaving
or choosing a new thought or positive
affirmation or Mantra that you can use
to overwrite Old unhelpful thought
patterns and then deliberately
practicing these actions and thoughts
until they become so strongly embedded
in your brain that they become the
default pathway for your brain to send
energy along
the more you repeat something and the
more emotional intensity there is
associated with it the more likely the
neurons are to wire together and form
new neural Pathways that make you the
new you and give you the best life that
you can have and this is really from the
root level up it's not superficial
Behavior change it's changing the way
that you now do things
the final part of that process is about
accountability we all have so many good
intentions but we don't always see them
through and that's why an app like
living ashram or a buddy that you're
going through this Behavior change
process with really helps you to be much
more successful than if you just have
vague thoughts about changing a way of
being or acting
the evidence from really committing to a
behavior change like this is so strong
that even the field of research around
epigenetics which is the effect of the
environment on your genes shows that if
you think in a different way act in a
new way give up lifestyle behaviors that
are actually holding you back from being
the best self that you can be things
like stress smoking drinking not
exercising eating badly that you can
actually change the expression of your
genes so we all have
um parts of our genes that can be
switched on or off so even if we have
certain
um
likelihoods of getting certain diseases
or living to a certain age
through our thoughts and our behaviors
we can change some of those outcomes
pretty incredible
one way to approach this is through
positive visualization
so you can visualize yourself healthy
and well and you can really take that to
the core of you and see yourself
exhibiting these good behaviors and
visualize the outcome that that would
have for you in the future
another way of priming your brain to
make sure that you stay accountable to
these goals that you really want to
reach is to create what I call an action
board
now this is like a vision board it's a
collage of images
metaphorical or literal that represent
all the things that you really want in
life
but the scientific part says that you
also have to take goal-orientated action
towards making these things come true
you can't just sit at home and fantasize
about them coming true
so if you create an action board you
look at it every day you visualize it
coming true
and you take the actions whether it's
from the brain Body Connection actions
that you committed to or something to do
with the longer more sustainable
Behavior change and you keep doing them
you'll see the results rolling in and
this really comes back to living
ashram's motto of root level up whole
human approach to wealth to health
wealth and well-being
um so it's about really committing and
seeing that through in every aspect of
your body your thoughts your emotions
and your spirit a strong negative
motivator gets us into action
um sometimes a really strong positive
one will do that too but not as strongly
as a negative motivator so I'm thinking
for example when I had my wedding come
up and I wanted to look a certain way
and for the whole wedding to feel a
certain way I did a lot of things I
wouldn't normally do to try to make sure
that happened but that was unusual and I
remember thinking then okay this is a
really positive motivator but most of
the time we do things to avoid a
perceived loss or we do things because
things have gone wrong for us and we
need to try to make it better and
actually that is very explained by
science because one of the strongest
gearings of our brain from evolution is
called loss avoidance and the brain is
two to two and a half times as primed to
avoid loss as it is to get a reward do
you remember I mentioned the um I
mentioned six ways of thinking I may not
have classified them as the brain
agility model you said what's the source
and I said it's your fully integrated
brain power
and so I I put that into six categories
which are mastering your emotions
knowing yourself which is the brain Body
Connection trusting your gut which is
intuition making good decisions it's
logic logic has to be in there but it's
just one of the six
um staying motivated and resilient to
reach your goals and then the final one
which is kind of the culmination of
those five is
um creating the life that you desire so
in that model
I talk about using all of the different
ways that you have to think
to to manifest real world outcomes but
I'd also like to say at this point that
I was one of those people who was told
at school that I wasn't creative because
I wasn't good at art
and so I wanted to create a faster or no
brother brother John was it it's a very
in Catholic High School sent me to the
Headmaster saying I couldn't be the
possibly be this bad at Art I must be
painting this way just to piss him off
yeah
so if you give me a paintbrush it
literally it and someday I will get to
challenge myself on that but that like
the root beer is still in me
well do you remember that quote from the
book
um
if somebody tells you you can't paint by
all means paint yes
um so I think you know I want to give
that to you as a as a gift
um
but yeah I mean things like that stay
with you for ages if you're like 11 and
you're told that you're not creative I
believed I wasn't creative till I was
35. I fully believed I was not creative
and all my friends are creative creative
and the obvious sense of the word and I
sort of thought isn't it strange how all
my friends are creative but I'm not and
there were a few friends that said but
you are but I was so shut off to
believing that that was true that I
didn't even question it or say what do
you mean or you know explore it
um so for me there was like a bang kind
of you know a crisis moment that changed
everything but one of the reasons I
wrote The Source is that that it
shouldn't have to be like that we could
you know we can all bring that into our
lives without necessarily having a
crisis so so I wanted to reframe
creativity and just make it about
creating your own life
um and and so man so manifestation is
basically
believing that you have more agency
around creating you know what you want
in your life rather than that life just
happens to you
um I totally understand that it feels
like that for people a lot of the time
um and you know I use this analogy where
I say if if you're going on a journey a
car journey and
um would you rather be the person in the
driving seat choosing the destination
and how you get there or are you happy
to be in the passenger seat and just be
driven around not know where you're
going and you know the the route that
you take
and so a lot for a lot of people life
can feel like you're in the passenger
seat and understanding Neuroscience is
about putting yourself in the driver's
seat
so the manifestation part is how much
can you contribute to actually bringing
into your life the things that you
really really want and so it's a bit of
a gray area because to me it overlaps
with Magnetic desire which is something
that you really really want so there's
to be a strong emotional component to it
and then the actions that draw that into
your life so I'm not one of those people
that says if you visualize something or
make a vision board or
you know imagine an ideal future that
you should just wait for it to come true
because you thought about it I'm very
much about doing the actions that um
move you know progress you towards that
goal becoming true
and so um the science around
manifestation and magnetic desire and
vision boards is a three-step concept in
the brain which is selective attention
selective filtering and value tagging
and basically we're bombarded with so
much information all the time everything
we smell here see everyone we meet but
the brain naturally filters most of that
out and
um brings our attention to the things
that are relevant for our survival and
to tags those things in order of
importance and there's both a logical
and an emotional component to why
certain things are important to us
so you can imagine if you're trying to
hold down the day job if you're trying
to put food on the table that
that filtering process happens quite
automatically and it's not thinking
what's the best thing that could ever
happen to me in my life well how do I
really want my life to look like in five
years time it's not doing that it's just
doing how do I survive like in the next
short term
so um
paying attention to manifestation
and one of the mediums for doing that as
a vision board is a way of priming your
brain to notice and grasp opportunities
that might otherwise have passed you by
the sort of the intentionality of what
you do so you can do
the same thing like okay so intermittent
fasting is a great example there's a
huge difference between between people
who say oh I forget to eat breakfast and
people who eat like me which is only
between 12 noon and 8 PM every day
because of the intention it actually has
a different effect on your body yeah
it's like your body's like burning more
because you're intentionally doing that
or you're losing my weight or something
I won't go so far as to say it's burning
more or you're losing more weight but
there's so again in Neuroscience there's
a difference between
um intentional mind wandering and just
slipping off into daydreaming and so if
you slip off into daydreaming that means
your attention isn't the best and it's
actually kind of a bad sign in terms of
your focus and your concentration but if
you intentionally let your mind wander
then actually that leads to more
creative thinking the threats have
changed from physical to psychological
or social
um although that thresh also existed
because we could only really Thrive as
part of a tribe in the cave and that was
literally for physical warmth as well as
affection and you know looking after
each other's children and sharing
responsibilities now there aren't as
many any in that way anyway physical
threats to our our safety or our life
but the social threat of being rejected
being lonely being abandoned
um that's still very very strong in our
wiring
um and then other things because
obviously now we have money for example
that the idea of losing your job losing
your lifestyle those have become you
know sort of potential social threats to
your safety as well and you know there's
so many more but I would say that
financial and relational have become the
biggest threats to our safety so
I think obvious examples of that are
staying in a relationship where you're
not really happy but you think well it's
better than being single again kind of
thing
um
and
because that wiring has been there for
so long and of course in Lacey's work
she talks about wiring that has been
there since childhood for us as
individuals and we have you know made it
very clear the longer an issue has been
there the harder it is to
um bring it from subconscious to
conscious and then deal with it this is
even beyond that this is for generations
and millennia so it's a very strong
default and it's really every decision
that you make is based on is the world a
safe place can I do this and still be
healthy and happy and you've mentioned a
specific which is not watching the news
well I don't know any neuroscientists
that I'm friends with who watches the
news and and that's the reason because
because we're
wired to default to loss of Virgin if we
continually tell our brain that there's
danger out there there's bad people out
there there's accidents out there
you will not want to you take the
healthy risks that you could to make
your life better because you're too
aware of the possible dangers
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing roles from Gabby Bernstein
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there appreciation
creates more of what you want
so if you've got something good going on
go appreciate it even more talk about it
thrive in it write about it